[Music]
three two one action hey guys welcome
back to off the record we do what we do
whatever we want
never mess that up ever not to be
mistaken with Dom the bro side here
right now my knees checked out until the
next order fascinating is the first I've
ever seen that character it's the first
time we've ever had a character i'm
jania [ __ ] is so [ __ ] hard how the
[ __ ] do you do that [ __ ] all the way
through I've been doing it for 10 years
so I think I've been Dom longer that
have been myself do you guys like
finding yourself you're like who am i
but it's like this character is very
distinct and it's just like it's why
it's at first maybe like a couple years
ago you know it started out as improv
stuffs when I first did it it was like
this we'd set up me and my my writing
part of the time we would set up a
camera and he would interview me about
topical [ __ ] and I would just sit there
and be in character put on the accent
and talk about it and then I would chop
it up into like a short three-minute bit
and that's really these jump cuts came
from so it started as improv but it was
um
you know I was good at it but it wasn't
something I did a lot so there's always
this anxiety of starting it out being
like am I gonna be funny today and
sometimes it just wouldn't have anything
to talk about and we'd shoot like this
isn't working half toucan it and then
start again when I started bro science
about three years later everything was
scripted so I wrote out an entire script
and then would add improv as we shoot so
it's just more comfortable being like I
know it's funny going in so I'm not
wasting my time but I also know I'm good
at improv and then as the years went on
I was like okay
the writing is becoming harder and
harder because I've done so many videos
and I try so hard to keep the content
fresh and I just started doing more
improv with Bradley Martin doing Bros
verse and that was all just like come up
with a concept jump into it and just be
in character and do like a sort of fake
reality show style thing and then I
realized that I was just good at doing
it when I didn't think about it I could
just be in character and then when I
edited myself I'm like that was way
funnier than I thought yeah kind of like
in your head thinking is this gonna be
funny but once you just kind of let it
go I look at I'm like this actually
turned out real
funny moments I didn't even know happen
and it sort of feels like you know you
can't black out switch a light on you
like in character then probably the best
yeah so now I'm at the point where like
I I almost prefer it cuz I don't have to
write anything I don't have to come
prepared I can just kind of enjoy it and
I've been doing it long enough that it's
literally just a light switch that's
crazy yeah we got our started YouTube me
embark on my characters first and
foremost and then when we were acting
ourselves like on JK news that was
[ __ ] weird or anytime I had to be
myself yeah that was rude I was so used
to being a character on on-camera so
when I had to speak like my own thoughts
and all that stuff I felt so awkward you
have this like protective barrier when
you're a carrot when you're a character
it's like a big coat yeah and you can
first and foremost with like an accent
or an over top character people just
know it's humour they're not wondering
if you're joking or if you're being
serious you believe something you get
away with a lot yeah but also you're
defending yourself from being like
putting your actual self out there so if
someone makes fun of you doesn't let it
judges you based on what you say or what
you think it's like yeah it's just a
character right but then once you put
yourself in front of camera you're like
okay that's really me and you know the
Internet is not the most uh forgiving
place to do that so and I just think a
exaggerated character is just a lot
funnier than a normal person it's always
gonna be yeah yeah is way funnier do you
get a lot of [ __ ] because I know like in
the fitness community um everyone is
like a [ __ ] pro everyone knows
everything so when you come in and like
you're making these jokes do people want
to [ __ ] in the kit Kiera listen I
surprisingly get no really like I just I
think because they won't they would not
survive it they like if someone wants to
come after Dom and they're gonna get
shredded like you do realize like my
character is a dumbass
I am a king of roasting this I've roast
I roast myself I roast everybody my
channel is roasting what you guys do so
no one wants that alright but also like
I'm making a point not to involve myself
in an actual personal beef like if
someone try to do that I honestly
wouldn't engage it I'd be like this is
not worth my time and whatever happens
but I most people just want to laugh at
themselves and
I think it's really surprising to see
that like the most surprising reaction
from certain fans is that you you
inspired me to lose weight or go to the
gym I'm like wow I'm like [ __ ]
seriously had people be like I lost a
hundred pounds because of you I'm like
did they use your actual bro science
texts that's the thing I'm like how it's
not an actual fitness channel and they
said because because you made the gym
more approachable because of your humor
it was like I thought they were taking
your advice like whatever the advice man
yeah no I got no I'm workout ever
there's no real fitness advice it took
your fake Fitness advice and then they
hear but even that there's not like real
workout advice you know it's more about
like the the culture or the the comunist
Society of gym culture whatever so in
seeing that I'm realizing because when I
think about how to make a video I first
and foremost think about myself like why
do I do the things I do when I go to the
gym what's the psychology behind
somebody acting a certain way and
usually you got to think okay why do I
do this sounds like then you can expand
that to other things you see and other
people and really it's once you address
that and clear the air people feel more
confident knowing that everyone else
does yeah laugh at yourself you can go
to the gym now and not feel like you're
being judged because this person before
was was in that same position or does
these same things and I didn't realize
that until I actually got people saying
that I inspired them to workout I'm like
[ __ ] man like I drink every weekend and
I just restart my workouts every other
week I'm not a fitness personality you
know I got on but yeah I guess it works
you have a duty prank calls as your
character that's how it started actually
cause no yeah this is like the hardest
thing that do in the world is think this
is how the character started um so me me
and my buddy were we were so he worked
at a pool company maybe in 2008 he was
one of the managers and I just worked
with him because you know nepotism so
he's another friend of ours was also
working he got a new work phone and we
used to do the accent we would talk to
each other the Dom DOM is Eddy accent or
from the Jersey and that was sort of
like more joking around
the thing he calls her on the phone she
doesn't know this number and she's like
hello he's like well like hi who's this
and he's just like Dom Dom who machete
just like that and then Dom is that he
was born right here friend but then it
I was also you know using the name and
the accent it initially was I wrote a
script for it in college I went to film
school and in a sketch writing class I
was doing a script where Donizetti was a
like a middle-aged og Italian with a
shitty cooking show it was like the the
first iteration of actual Dom is Eddie
behind
beyond me and my friend is [ __ ]
around that only was a script and then
when we started shooting YouTube videos
it was around the four loko era that's
the video that got popular and I was
like instead of just being this like
middle-aged guy like just be this
character who inserts himself to all
these situations still an expert but
just talks about mainly college topical
thing so I was talking about my night
four loko weird all his crazy [ __ ] like
a two-minute video just a bunch of jump
cuts talking about all those wild should
I did sat tiring but you know being a
satire on the people you would hear
after a weekend because I got so blacked
out on full low quite jealous wild [ __ ]
and usually it wasn't that wild it was
just them blacking out everybody misses
four loko dude everybody misses it off
the market because she was a [ __ ]
crazy legal substance right it was the
combination of caffeine and alcohol I
think is what they made it to be well
what about all rebel LOC I'm like that's
something you make yeah I can't sell a
Red Bull vodka you can't combine it yeah
four loko had something some other [ __ ]
in it though because I've never gotten
so [ __ ] up on something in my life
that's what they say man we're for local
was weird dude like I had it once I was
like never again yeah I never tried it
so when I found out that they
discontinued it I was like dang it was
there like a banned substance like a
fedra or some [ __ ] in a - I don't know
what it was but it just got people
[ __ ] up and from just one can like
that's all you need I don't know I have
some a lot of other people yeah one can
is pretty much pretty intense and the
kids [ __ ] huge too by the way it's a
tall boy
I still I drank one recently it's sort
of it's it the same it's still
disgusting yeah it doesn't have the
energy in it so but it's sort of like a
funny thing some people some people when
they found out he was getting off the
market they just bought [ __ ] Bob
loads of it oh I think like some people
still have up for like special occasions
and [ __ ] yeah but you can't buy him
anymore my [ __ ] wedding I'm gonna
Busters are the lost art type of [ __ ] is
vintage 2010 yeah that's it got banned
the weekend my video came out oh that
was why it was like it did really really
well yeah there was a agent like wine
what was it called again pre-workout oh
jack3d
go at least I love that [ __ ] yeah that
was it strongly I used to take that
twice a day yeah [ __ ] Jack that [ __ ]
was amazing dude yeah I've never tried
it but everyone that I heard was like
this is there that was like the biggest
everybody only used Jack when I went to
college at the time because legit you
could like lift weights play like four
full court basketball games and then go
study after I used to do it for
everything I would wake up in the
morning take some later that day I work
out but then obviously I just skip that
part and go right to the next pre
workout I was taking the afternoon and
workout again but then I was going a
spring break and I would take it in the
morning workout before going to the pool
party at the pool go home die nap
I don't think so Blair after that so but
like I was like it was bad that was a
like meth or some [ __ ] and I forgot what
it was raspberry meth yeah but it was
great so I gave it to a Joseph Vincent
because I had one pre-workout of that
[ __ ] left when I first came to LA and it
was already bad by then but I found it
in one of my boxes when I was moving for
when I went when I went from Riverside I
moved back to Sacramento I still had one
[ __ ] pre-workout thing left and so
[ __ ] they banished it so I was using it
again and I gave it to this YouTube and
they chose a visit to play basketball
and he's never taken a pre-workout
before I gave him
it did for you play like four or five
like full-court games at 24 that foot
went to the hospital the next day
because he has such bastions he couldn't
walk because he felt invincible he was
like yo let's keep going and keep going
because I gave him a full scoop full
court like the entire court like not
just two baskets it was like dude I felt
great in the next day he would've asked
because he could have walked that shins
hurt so much how to do it man that [ __ ]
was great though workouts crazy
I remember when one of the first times
you took it yeah it scared the [ __ ] out
of me and he started going ham on squats
and like yet it was my first time doing
squats yeah and then he was like one
plate he's like [ __ ] yeah two plates and
then you were just like do you want to
just chill Isaac no I feel good I didn't
even get in my car the next day I was so
jacked man which people go did you take
animal pump you have an animal pump or
something you get you some NAR pump
that's my pre-workout ooh your own label
yeah yeah after that I got scared a
pre-workout cuz I felt invincible dude I
was like every single bank in California
it's mad it's like PCP pillage all these
villages it's a mental thing is you feel
so like nothing can hurt you
yeah and you just feel so energetic and
on top of that that does not like math
yeah and you know what's funny I've done
math and it did god there's Matt you
look at the meth you go yeah give me the
free word Street [ __ ] man you don't want
the math you want the real fine shitty
cuz you would start off you know just
warming up and you feel okay but after
you would get into like your whatever
second or third of workout it just boom
kicks and I just remember I just going
forever and then we just wouldn't stop
and that I mean the crash was pretty
hard but what if I gotta take again
later
oh it's going down a little bit just
scoop it a little bit more and you're
good because I would just take half a
scoop and I would take another half a
scoop later because it was so [ __ ]
awful few workouts never hit me that
hard and after I had so many really yeah
it's never hit me that hard and the only
time I could do it is like in
competition yeah cuz then I'm like
there's adrenaline pumping and I'm like
why good I'll get you something that's
crazy that because you don't even take
that much because I would think of
caffeine tolerances yeah it never gets
me so only in competition only for
deadlifts I would take cuz I'm like well
I guess I need it at this point but
other than that like but I'd never feel
it you see all those [ __ ] UFC
fighters the way they take me workout
they just [ __ ] take two scoops and
it's eat that [ __ ] yeah that's the way
to do it you got to do it what do they
just do like fun dip man yeah
extra fun I know those guys to train
with TJ Dillashaw and he says to keep up
with him he had to take pre-workout six
times a day they have to Train so much
like they have like a boxing boxing
session than a wrestling session than a
BJJ session and a Muay Thai session like
a Street conditioning session and he
just has to constantly just take this it
might be a dumb question but is that bad
because you are exerting that much
amount of energy I'm I guess you have to
do it so you do all that and you got to
figure out your weight how to recover
from all that to you how do you sleep
you guys I mean but you're exhausted cuz
you've your heart is probably all right
- well you probably work your way up to
that being your norm so your cap at work
capacity in just builds but that just
seems not human yeah it's insane I've
never felt the positive effects of BCAAs
though like after I was the recovery
should you take a pre-workout you know
the immediate effect right there like
your sort
take these BCAAs I might I still [ __ ]
sober you [ __ ] like a faster
recovery yeah some people think it helps
chain amino acids yeah I mean I really
know it's like fish away
it's literally like vitamins right like
how do you know that the vitamins are
making you
Canada's hope there's like one or two
clinical studies that show if your
trainer asks often you take BCA's that
it prevents your muscles from breaking
down during the training but that's just
only a few one handful of studies but is
it other really test it tastes good let
me just there you go that's that's one
for B vitamins right like most people
drink drink more water yeah you see
people with like an entire glowing pink
thing of the gallon water drink helps
people drink water I guess I people like
it I've only ever had a quarter of
pre-workout and that one tiny little
thing that I got my heart was like
smelled us when the canister open it has
like a warning label to like if you
don't take me workout you you have to
have a certain amount that's really just
gave me a tiny little thing of it and I
still like oh my god hey the doctors oh
[Laughter]
he's a doctor like it take ask a core
scoop of pre-work again who told you Lou
the doctor dr. Lou do you work out like
often too it's like that's still a huge
part of your life even though you're
playing your character yeah I mean I was
into the gym before the whole bro
science thing I was actually a personal
trainer for about two weeks but when I
was four you two didn't like that it
wasn't for me I realize the only thing I
like about working out is when I work
like I don't want to write a workout
plan working out with people or do you
like working out by yourself
usually with people but recently just by
myself I think there's always a sort of
something you do every day for so long
right you just kind of go through phases
of whatever doesn't Cory at the time
you're like I've sometimes don't want to
be bogged down by having a schedule with
other people or whatever feel like being
a personal trainer is like a babysitter
yeah that's exactly what it is and a
therapist did you do this oh and a
therapist yeah cuz it's like half of
this session you're talking about why
your boyfriend or girlfriend is mad at
yeah not that I've had for personal
train but I've just I know enough
you know accurate I feel you just you as
a trainer you get so mentally drained
you're like taking everybody's [ __ ]
baggage five yeah do you
so has it be a very specific type of
human being to want to be a personal
trainer it wasn't me
because I've seen personal trainers at
gyms you could tell like they probably
don't have the best clientele and
they're not making a lot of money cuz
they don't care well the thing is it's
such a wide range of what people know
and in Fitness and what like you know
some studies prove to be true and some
studies prove the exact opposite people
believe this people believe that and
maybe you're just sort of like someone
who took the test and became a trainer
and just rights should you workout plans
maybe you're someone that actually knows
and there's just such a variance and
there's no real consistency there so
like to find a good personal trainer
you're kind of committing like I got to
commit a couple weeks to see progress or
the lack of to at least know and you're
like well I just lost a bunch of money a
lot of times yeah it's this kind of a
confusing thing sometimes this is so
we're just like just there's so much
information out there it's hard to
filter through everything right because
there's how many X amount of diets have
come out recently the carnivore diet you
know there's the Paleo this this and
that and every single one of them are
arguing with each other about who's
better exactly yeah so it's like well
what the [ __ ] and they have like their
set of data and their scientist has say
this and there's their data this is this
and I'm like what I don't know who's
[ __ ] right at this point then so I
just make fun of it just step back and
I'm like you know I'm gonna be in as
good a shape as I can be while still you
know partying on the weekends and not
being too bogged down by all the science
and I had to learn when I was a personal
trainer for two weeks this isn't this
isn't what I like about fitness so yeah
that's the best though you get best of
both worlds where you get to practice
your passion but then you don't have to
be too in it you know like I think in
hobbies like people take it way too
[ __ ] serious but at the same time I
also get the worst of both worlds
because in the eyes of a lot of my fans
not only do I have to be funny but I
also have to be jacked in and shape all
the time oh that's a lot of pressure
yeah so it's like I got a do you know
the fitness influencer thing but also a
comedian thing I'm like I'm not a
fitness influencer but I got it I got to
keep up comedy first man I did because
when I started with comedy person and I
got a little bit into fitness they it's
like it's like that dumb kid in class
that
finally started to read you get a gold
star yeah so I do like I do a little bit
I set the bar so low I do a little bit
and everyone's proud of me
but that's what I did it just the
mistake I made was coming into you know
bringing comedy into Fitness's I am the
biggest guy in the world that's like
that's the attitude like I know
everything and of course it's satire but
at the end of the day there are still
people who I just look up to DOM is
there you really do have to look the
part too because I had this character
called Kim Jong Ella
he's like the North Korean dictator yeah
and I lost like 60 pounds it doesn't
work mmm like it doesn't work yeah you
got to look like him then shot it we we
I shot a pilot for it and this was like
in-between where I lost like 30 pounds
and even then it wasn't this funny and
that's like all cuz I just don't look
like him that much anymore
so like the character digit really does
play into it sometimes being fat adds 50
fat funny points the fat buddy pause
dude
[Music]